You okay?
Okay? Yeah I'm alright, yeah. How
are you, you alright? Yeah. Why, what?
I dunno, you kind of just seem a bit distracted or
something. Distracted? No, no, I'm alright.
I'm not distracted.
Okay cool, so I got the tickets to Venice for
March.
That's... terrific, really terrific.
Terrific.
You know I think that like some souls, are
kind of they're meant to together beyond space,
time, whatever. Look babe, like born to be
together but I also think that might not necessarily
mean they should be together on a day to day
basis.
So, are you saying you don't want to be with
me any more?
NO, no not at all no. That's so simple, it's
way more complicated than that.
I cannot deal with this. What do you even
want from me? I'm sorry, I don't get it. Like
where do you imagine this is even going to
go?
Look why can't we just instead of overthinking
it just you know, not ruin the evening and
you know order a pizza and watch a film together
and have some fun.
Hey, come on. I love you, come on. It pains
me to hear you like this.
I know you get a bit down on your birthday
so I got you this.
This is the last one. Are you going to be
alright?
Sure.
I don't love you anymore and I'm sorry. I
know it hurts but it's how I feel.
You just need some space.
Mmm, I don't, I'm not sure that space... I
could all the space I want but I think I would
end up occasionally maybe wanting to sleep with
you but nothing more so I think I just can't
really see us having a future. I think, erm,
I think you should move on.